[Music]
speaker Pelosi is opening up a new front
her war against the Trump administration
and Republican leadership in Congress
here she is taking a shot at my next
guest
leader McConnell seems to take great
pride in calling himself the grim reaper
it's part of his political campaign it's
part of the prize he takes this leader
of the Senate and as you see what he
wants to bury none of these things are
going to pass they won't even be voted
on so think of me as the grim grim
reaper the grim reaper what well Senator
McConnell your response to these new
attacks from Nancy Pelosi complete
senator with props and poster boards
McConnell's graveyard she's got it right
she's got it right for the first time in
my memory I agree with Nancy Pelosi I am
indeed the grim reaper when it comes to
the socialist agenda that they've been
ginning up over in the house with
overwhelming Democratic support and
sending it over to America things that
would turn us into a country we've never
been there on the way to doing some
additional things in addition ones
they've already done at the green New
Deal Medicare for all and by the way you
may have mentioned this on your show but
they in planned planned to make the
District of Columbia state that given to
new democratic senators Puerto Rico
State we give them two more New
Democratic senators and the former
Supreme Court Clerk yourself you've
surely noticed that they plan to expand
the Supreme Court so this is a full-bore
socialism on the march in the house and
yeah as long as I'm the majority to the
Senate none of that stuff is going
anywhere senator is there anything that
can get done for the good of the country
with this hot political climate that
we're in I mean we're going to talk
about this crisis at the border what
we're seeing with with people coming
across the border several hundred just
in the last few weeks from African
countries now well I can tell what we're
gonna do on the humanitarian
the problem down at the border Senate
Democrats insisted on stripping that out
it's fair to say the president's had
more cooperation for the Mexicans that
he has from this house and Senate
Democrats so far on dealing with this
Christ well the other yeah the other
thing we're hearing a lot from even some
of your Republican colleagues is this
concern that you refused to move
legislation that would protect the
country from future election meddling
the New York Times writing in a piece
today partisan politics is the reason
McConnell is standing in the way of
better election security for him all
that matters is the win even if he
compromises and corrupts our democracy
senator that's what they're saying about
you and saying look even Marco Rubio
wants some legislation yeah What
nonsense look I think you ought to
compare the 2018 election when the Trump
administration was in charge to the 2016
election when the Obama administration
was in charge any stories about the last
election just a handful of minor stories
this administration did a terrific job
of working with state and local
officials to make sure we had an honest
election in 2018 with minimal to no
interference where's the applause for
that I'm open to considering legislation
but it has to be directed in a way that
doesn't undermine state and local
control of elections the Democrats Laura
would like to nationalize everything
they want the federal government to take
over broad swaths of the election
process because they think that would
somehow benefit them election security I
do care about but we need to make sure
the subjects is election security and
Senator of course the big news yesterday
was when George Stephanopoulos sidles
around the oval office desk and presents
this scenario to the president where
foreign government comes and plops down
opera research about his
opponent and the president said well
maybe I'd go to the FBI but I'd probably
listen to the information do you have a
problem with that answer because the
Democrats seem to be taking that and
saying AHA see we told you so now it's
on to impeachment they just can't let it
go Laura
you know I said weeks ago case closed
we've got the Muller report the only
objective evaluation that will be
conducted nobody has any confidence that
the Democratic House is going to engage
in any kind of appropriate oversight the
case is closed why don't we move on and
solve the border crisis and prove the
president's us MCA the new trade deal
with Mexico in Canada we have work to do
but do you think the president do you
think the president made a mistake in
the way he answered that question when
he said maybe I would maybe I wouldn't
you know I'd hear what I'd hear him out
would you answer that question that well
I think it gets he gets picked at every
day over every different aspect of it
but the fundamental point is they're
trying to keep the 2016 election alive
and the investigation alive when the
American people have heard enough they
got the Muller report they would like
for us to do some business I would ask
the Democrats in the house this is there
anything you're willing to do other than
harass the president for the next two
years anything at all and senator
finally I want to turn to the courts an
issue obviously you care near a lot
about with all the confirmations
successful that you've gotten through
and president Trump has always been
pretty transparent about potential
nominees however I think the left is
basically getting ready to as you
mentioned earlier try to pack the courts
in the unlikely event that they win in
2020 it's all being funded we found out
yesterday by dark money groups who won't
you know names
we won't know are not going to be
revealed and this comes as Ron Klain a
former Obama and Clinton aide warns
quote the next decade could feature a
radical right Supreme Court that would
not only narrow past gains but also
erect barriers to prevent progressive
political action so which is it will the
courts be champions for the laughter
they just too taught too darn far right
the kind of people the president's been
dominating and
been confirming believing the simple
quaint notion that maybe judges ought to
follow the law I'm amazed that that's
controversial but they're being upset
about it reveals that they want the
judiciary to be just like a legislative
body and to have outcomes in mind before
they've heard the arguments with regard
to the nominees not only the president
made two great Supreme Court nominees
and Neil Gorsuch and Brett Kavanaugh but
we're making an important difference for
the country that will last for a very
long time and my motto for this Congress
is leave no vacancy behind either in
circuit judges or district judges
all right Senator McConnell thanks so
much for spending some time with us
tonight we really appreciate it thank
you Laura